So last Friday,
the progressive website mother Jones
included me in an article about a quote
new extremist media industry that is
further to the right than Breitbart in
the piece.
The author referred to me as quote far
right sighting interviews I've done with
Mike Cernovich,
Milo Yiannopoulos and lauren southern to
backup his accusation.
He Cherry picked these guests to fit his
narrative,
yet somehow miss the endless amount of
liberals I've had on the show and some
of the progressive's I've hosted as
well,
including Margaret Cho,
Hilary Rosen,
mark duplass,
John Fugal sang and Michael Ian Black.
The article also attack Patrion the
crowd funding platform,
which myself and my team's livelihood
depends on for being tolerant of people
with quote far right views such as mine
though of course,
nowhere did it include any of my
purported far right views.
Earlier in the week,
Forbes called the Rubin report,
a conservative talk show,
but immediately retracted the statement
when I contacted them.
Ironically,
I've been saying for a while that
defending my liberal beliefs is becoming
a conservative position.
Although I don't think being called a
conservative is somehow a pejorative.
It clearly isn't a proper descriptor for
this show in which I posted people from
across the political divide for Mother
Jones to accuse me of being an
extremist.
Further to the right of Breitbart is
obviously an inflammatory and
demonstrably dishonest statement.
I've been around many people over the
last few years who've been unfairly
maligned and I'm all too familiar with
how this goes,
whether it's Sam Harris,
Jordan Peterson,
Collin Moriarty,
I Ayaan,
Hirsi Ali or Bret Weinstein.
Each attack is virtually never based on
what these people have said,
but is instead crafted out of Straw man
arguments with the words racist and
bigot tossed around like Andy.
Suddenly the onus is on the people who
aren't racists or bigots to disprove
this accusation,
usually slung by a misguided celebrity
or a malicious newspaper or website.
The move then is on the accused.
Should they spend the time and energy
defending themselves from accusations
which aren't true,
only to bring more attention to the
accusations themselves or should they
ignore them,
hoping that the false claims will go
away over time?
I think there are solid arguments to be
made for either tactic and it truly
depends on the situation at hand and the
person involved in this case involving
me,
I went on the attack,
I decided this case was to agregious to
ignore and I contacted the articles
author via twitter,
screenshotting pieces of his article and
asking him to defend them.
Of course he couldn't defend his own
words.
That's the thing with truth.
It's hard to work around and eventually
he made slight changes to the article
like including a tweet of mine in which
I defended myself from his claims and he
removed the word far in front of the
word right before referencing me in the
article,
putting the rest of the specifics of the
article itself,
I was happy to get a strong defense in
public for many friends all over the
political map.
People like Joe Rogan,
Collin Moriarity,
Feisal site,
all Matar,
Bret Weinstein,
Eric Weinstein,
Michael Shermer,
Peter Posey,
and in many others offered strong
defenses of me just as I've offered for
others when I've seen them unfairly
attacked.
I even got a public defense from Donald
Trump jr putting my friends in public
allies aside though it's incredibly
inspiring and humbling to see literally
tens of thousands of people offer their
voice when they feel you've been
unjustly attacked.
And that's the key to this whole thing.
It's not me or Sam or Jordan or Brett
that they fear.
What they really fear is that all of
you,
we'll start saying what you think
because there's strength in numbers.
By Monday I wanted to put this whole
story behind me.
My dog had a health emergency,
which actually put this whole thing into
perspective.
Uh,
but I admit I did get sucked back into
the story very briefly over the course
of another twitter exchange.
I got the writer of the piece,
Josh Harkinson to publicly admit that I
am not further right than Breitbart.
Though of course he didn't change the
title or have mother Jones issue any
sort of public correction.
One other interesting piece to all this
is that the writer,
Josh Harkinson is one of the 40 people
that James Hodgkinson,
the shooter of the Republican Baseball
team last week in Virginia,
followed on twitter.
Now,
I can't draw a direct link there,
but we know that Hodgkinson was a far
left lefty who was obviously driven to
political extremes,
so when this very same writer does a
hatchet job on me calling me further,
right than Breitbart,
which is clearly a code for racist,
I can't sit back there and take it.
This is exactly why I've been saying you
can't punch Nazis call everyone.
You oppose a Nazi and a racist and then
eventually you will see violence as the
next logical step.
It's not a crazy exercise to think that
this is partially what drove James
Hodgkinson.
In hindsight.
His attack on me was the next obvious
step in where this whole collectivist
movement is going.
I've talked for a long time about how if
you can't debate ideas,
you use lies in buzzwords.
Having a turned on me shouldn't have
been a surprise,
especially from a leftist site like
mother Jones.
Yet somehow it did still surprise me.
Make no mistake.
There is a think acquisition going on
here and it can come for anyone at any
time.
If you ally yourself with people who
value the movement,
in this case a political movement over
you as an individual,
then eventually it is inevitable that
they will come for you and if they don't
come for you,
your probably the one coming for them.
This think was issued will come after
anyone who bucks the trend and the
stereotypes and dares think for
themselves.
It's why they accused Ayaan Hirsi Ali of
being anti Muslim.
It's why they slander Bill Maher as
being a racist.
It's why they call Larry elder and uncle
Tom and it's apparently they can brand
me a far right extremist.
Those who are a part of this thing,
acquisition fear you thinking for
yourself that you won't bow to their
collectivists demands more than anything
else.
The way to beat this witch hunt is to be
yourself and fight for what you believe
you are the antidote that they fear
most.
I hope that next time you see me
fighting back and getting some cover
from my allies,
it will inspire you to fight back
specifically with words,
not violence as well.
Joining me on the show this week is one
of my afro mentioned allies and a friend
and author and professor Peter
Boghossian,
who's going to help me dissect some of
the madness of 2017 and much more.
Joining me today is an author and a
professor of philosophy at Portland
State University and a man who strives
to be a good human every day.
Peter [inaudible],
welcome back.
It's great to be here.
Thanks and thanks for the striving to be
a good human.
You'd never know it from what people
have been saying about us.
Well certainly about me,
about you.
You really been through the ringer in
the last few days and I would love to
get to that and talk about that.
I suspect we can get to that,
but strives to be a good human being.
The reason I threw that in there,
because that seems to me you were on the
show about a year and a half ago.
We had never met before that we've since
become very good for her in front of me.
Hit A,
we hit it off instantly just like that
and when you were on the show and we'll
link to it down below so that people can
see the initial sit down.
Um,
I felt that it was one of the episodes
where so many of the things that I had
been thinking about,
about the left,
about politics,
about religion and so many of the things
sort of all came to get whole.
I actually,
they really did and I felt I felt richer
after.
And I do often in some interviews,
some interviews I feel dumber,
but this was one way I felt richer and
since we've become friends,
but you do strive to be a pretty decent,
I do.
As you know,
you said,
how should I introduce you in the
beginning?
And I was thinking don't ask that.
Normally the only reason I asked is
because we're friends and I thought
maybe there's some person,
a little anecdote or something that you
want to,
and I really,
I really just striving to be a good
person.
I think that that's one of the things
that matter is that kindness,
that compassion.
I think we've so lost it and acrimonious
and we're so hyper partisan where so and
the college craziness and everything
that's been going on and they at the
attacks and the people will give you an
opportunity to respond to those attacks
and the negativity on social media.
So yeah,
I'm just trying to be a good guy and was
trying to live a good life,
a good life.
So in the last couple of months you lost
your dad.
I did.
That was the seminal event of one of the
seminal events in my life.
How do you stay a good person throughout
that?
Not that,
not that losing someone's going to make
you a bad person obviously,
but you're still trying to work.
You're still trying to be a public
person and to and like how do you manage
not just going nutty.
And in the course of that I had some
health issues.
I was in the emergency room three times
the last few months I have Crohn's
disease.
So that that's not doing me any favors
either.
Without getting too deep.
I mean,
you were in the hospital today.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you want me to tell it to people,
stuff going on.
But I think open about it and I think
that that,
that really does make every moment of
your life precious.
And when my,
my dad died and my mom died,
um,
I dunno,
it's a kind of a combination of feeling
more circumspect.
And I,
and I've always had in the back of my
mind,
my parents have probation or what my dad
think or my mom thing.
And it's kind of really given me an
opportunity to,
I'm trying to frame it positively,
it trying to given me me an opportunity
to reflect on what they did for me in my
life and try to do that for my kids.
But yeah,
when living navigating that reality,
when your parents have died,
it's very intense.
It's very,
you know,
even little things like you get in the
car,
he shot,
he's getting the car and she'd call my
dad or I call my mom and I don't do that
anymore.
And I think one of the,
that's why I was thinking today,
I don't like the idea that someone
passed it.
They,
they're debt,
they've died.
There's a permanence to that and that
language.
And I am always taking to myself like,
oh my mom would like that,
my dad like that.
And the real quick one,
my,
my mom died.
Uh,
it wasn't really into her funeral that I
understood that she died,
like really grokked it because someone
fell asleep and her funeral.
And I thought,
God,
my mom would think that's hilarious.
She would love that.
And then I realized like I could never
tell her that I could never tell her
anything again.
And those pillars in your life that you
can't go to in times of joy in times of
stress,
you know,
it was in the hospital for another time
for my Crohn's disease.
My Dad stayed up with me all night.
He was there.
And that part of my life is gone now.
Yeah.
So as a philosophy professor and as a
well known and outspoken atheist,
when,
when you're challenged with something
like the death of a parent,
did any of your beliefs get challenged?
I mean,
is there a moment at right after your
dad passed where you thought,
man,
I want to believe,
or did you maybe have a dream that
seemed different?
You know,
something like that because you know,
you know my feelings on roof and I,
and I'm not a believer in the
traditional sense,
and yet occasionally things happen that
I go,
what was that after my,
my grandma passed too.
I was very close with,
I'm sorry,
I had some very vivid dreams that seem
to me,
she was telling me something.
No,
I'm not,
I'm not saying I buy it for all of this,
but it has some value to me.
Did you have any of that or no?
Have any of that?
No.
I was just incredibly bereaved and I
was,
uh,
it mean it was just a shattering of a
type of reality for me.
And,
but it also made me realize that it
really is true,
that every moment of life is precious.
Just have to be so grateful.
Go through life with a sort of gratitude
for the experiences that you have.
So when you hear someone like me that
you know pretty well say,
well,
you know,
my grandma passed away and then,
I mean I can tell you about the dream.
I was in her apartment,
she looked amazing,
she was like glowing and she was wearing
all black and she had these like green
neon streaks in her hair and she was
like running in place really fast.
And she was telling me how excited she
is and she has all these things to do.
I mean it was,
and it was vivid and powerful and
whatever.
And so when you hear me say something
like that as,
as a nonbeliever w,
what do you think of that?
I think it's totally normal and totally
natural.
I think different people grieve in
different ways.
And I think it was when my grandfather
died,
I had a similar experience.
I,
uh,
have a hyper vivid dream about him.
I think these moments in life,
life,
death,
they're really,
they give you a kind of clarity
sometimes,
but they also get,
so here's,
so for my dad,
when,
when he died and I was holding my dad's
hand and his death and my mom seeing
her,
her death.
So I was incredibly fortunate,
you know,
they saw me into the world and I saw
them out of the world.
I was just irreconcilable.
I mean I was just so,
I was a complete mess.
I was.
And the woman who comes in and the
social worker would have,
you said,
you know,
normally we have grief counselors here
and normally I would suggest to say,
but in your case I really think you have
to go see the grief counselor.
Like I'm sending supersede the grief
counselor in there is.
And I think part of that was so hard for
me is precisely because they don't have
those metaphysical beliefs.
Like it's the finality.
Like that's it.
So we'll see.
So then did you have moments through
these?
So you didn't,
I guess you're saying you really didn't
have a moment where suddenly you've got,
maybe I got this wrong or,
or I want to believe in something that I
can't prove,
but [inaudible] really it's really that
locked for you.
Like,
oh no,
it's not locked.
I just never bartered my hope for
anything.
You know,
I never,
I never as a great line.
Oh yeah.
Everybody was my hope for anything.
That's true though.
I mean I never,
and then the,
you go through the long run.
I was living in his house.
I was driving,
his cars weren't as close because right
after we did the event with Christina
Hoff Summers,
the next day that I went,
I went out there to see him.
But yeah,
it was fortunate.
And you know,
one thing that people really don't want
to talk about,
I think the left and the right has their
own blind spots.
But parenting,
I am absolutely convinced is a
prophylactic to bad behavior,
good parenting.
And if you look at the data,
kids are more likely to commit violent
crimes if they're in a certain age
group.
I just read this and I was reading Math
Thorton's manuscript above violence and
if there are males and if there's no
adult male president of the home and
just as the left doesn't want to
acknowledge that and talk about that.
So too does the right have particular
blinders about structural inequality and
such.
But I think parenting and good parenting
and being thoughtful and what that
means.
When I was the,
when I was driving down here,
the Uber driver told me that,
um,
I'm not going to mention what country
she was from and I'm looking at 50,000
emails,
these people and,
and no,
no.
Can you pick a,
give me the same hemisphere.
Southeast Asia.
Okay,
fair.
It was telling me that they come from a
traditional family and I asked,
why doesn't your,
why don't your kids go to see your ex?
And she said,
well,
he used to spank them.
And I thought like,
wow,
I've never raised my hand to my children
ever.
I have raised my voice on occasion.
I've never lost my temper.
It doesn't speak to me.
I think Denmark smacked me once or twice
in an argument.
And more than that.
But that's the other thing.
It's this idea about verbal violence.
It's the idea.
It's a complicated,
but I think parenting,
I think we've overlooked how important
that is.
Oh,
one more thing.
One thing,
since we're talking about this and
planning on talking about this,
they have no plan here.
The nurse said something really
interesting to me.
She said,
I bet you he was a wonderful father to
you.
And I said,
well,
you say that to everybody.
And she said,
actually,
no,
I don't.
I,
I can tell by the way the kids treat
their parents when they come to the
hospital and this,
it was so sad.
So I would walk into this hospital every
day and I would see all these people who
were literally dying and they were alone
and they had nobody.
And it just made me what kind of a
loneliness,
you know?
Yeah.
Is that the funny thing about not
unbelief that you've so obviously had a
transcendent experience,
but it's all based in actually what
happened.
So a lot of times,
I don't know,
like I had a father,
he was a physical person.
He lived in my home,
he raised me.
Oh,
and this a thing.
So I,
I,
so what did I do when my father died
after you know,
sobbing.
And the first person I called was my
childhood friend.
Like the next person who had known me
for the longest time and he cheered me
up and it was good.
Or he tried to,
you know,
that's connected to the family thing.
Don't you think?
I've mentioned this a couple of times
lately that I think now at 41 next week,
I just started to really understand,
thanks.
I've started to understand why the
family thing is so important and that
I'm so proud that my parents had been
married for 40 some odd years and I
still go home to the same childhood home
and my family friends are all still
there.
My,
my best friend in the world is still the
same guy that I met before kindergarten.
We were worried that those connections
have incredible value.
That's what the,
you know,
what is the meaning of life?
Well,
you know,
whatever,
you make the meaning life b.
But Aristotle talks about that.
And here's what I would throw out to you
and to the audiences that you can have
the richest,
deepest,
most rewarding friendships if you are a
person of virtue and the person with
whom you're friends with is a person of
virtue.
Aristotle says it's the highest form of
friendship between two virtuous people
and what does that entail?
And it really does until it kind of
Greek cop parrishcea speaking truth in
the face of danger.
So,
and I've told you a few things and
you've told me a few things,
hey,
I think you're wrong about this or have
you.
And if that is sufficient to decide that
we're going to part ways,
then either our friendship wasn't that
strong and the first place.
Or I would like to think that we have
the sort of relationship that we can be
completely honest with each other.
And even really I wouldn't spare your
feelings about something frankly,
which is what you and I exactly what
true French.
And then I would expect that you would
expect that.
I wouldn't spare your feelings and I
would just say,
hey look man,
this is how it is.
You did this and I have to say,
and then whatever it was I was telling
you about this right before we started.
So without even saying this,
the sex or name of the person certainly
or anything like that.
I got into a bit of a,
an argument with a friend of mine,
a public person just yesterday and we
really got into it on the phone and I
made it clear and I've done this a
couple times lately,
made it clear with people that even if
we're apoplectically angry at each
other,
this is not going to end the friendship,
at least for me.
Awesome.
And I feel very,
that comes very easy for me to say that
I,
it really does.
And I don't know why that's so hard for
other people to do that.
We're so now willing and maybe it is a
social media thing in a short attention
span thing or something like we're so
willing to just shred things that we've
had yet lends itself to a really
interesting question.
What would be,
since we're talking personally,
if I may,
what would be a deal breaker for
relationship?
And I was at dinner with my family a few
weeks ago and my son,
you've met my son.
Yeah,
I junior kid almost always keep my
family's names.
And so far it started talking about one
of the things you've learning about in
school is gender and social constructs
and sex changes.
And he said to my wife,
if dad decided to become a woman,
would you still be married to him?
And my wife without an instance of
hesitation said no.
And both my children were flabbergasted,
but they couldn't.
They couldn't.
And then they kept pressing her and she
said basically,
you know,
this isn't what I signed up for and,
and it just made me think.
So what are the limits of friendship?
Like what would the limits of
friendship,
I mean I can think of a few things.
Well if you,
if I found out that you murdered
somebody,
you're a cold blooded murderer or you
had done something so duplicitous
directly related to me too,
or even even I would have made me even
to someone else.
Or I'm in Korea.
Yeah,
it doesn't have it.
We couldn't make a scale like,
but what if I started filling my pockets
when you're in the kitchen with grapes
and that I saw in the fray.
Great.
See,
I told you you could have anything out
of it.
I know,
I know right now.
The funny thing is we'd have a
relationship.
I didn't ask.
I was,
I take it anyway,
so,
so like what if I went into your bedroom
when you were gone and went through your
drugs like there,
there are,
there are.
You know what those limits are,
are different.
But I would,
I suggest that it really comes down to
virtue and trust and those sorts of
relationships give your life so much
meaning and are so fulfilling and are so
profound.
They make for a life worth living.
And Nat,
I think what we need to put front and
center in our lives and even that stuff
on addiction is fascinating.
Um,
rice addiction medicine doctor.
And she gave this really interesting
presentation about how one of the,
the reasons that people become and stay
addicts and all the studies,
and this is the art of my area of
expertise,
but basically these does these studies
on rad parks and when rats are given
wheels and fun thing or habit trails
wherever wraps,
like they're much less likely to choose
narcotics then if they're not.
And one of those things is these
relationships that we develop and we
nurture throughout our lives.
And I guess I would like to be the sort
of person for whom being a person of
integrity and virtue and having those
deeply fulfilling relationships enhances
my life and my friendship.
And then when you call me and you say,
hey,
this is up.
Thanks for that,
I appreciate you did this.
And that was as a massive dick move.
Thanks.
I appreciate that.
So I know we've talked about,
we've definitely talked about this
privately,
but I think we may have talked about it
last time also,
but I think it'd be good to recharge if
someone does exactly what you just said,
find that virtuous life but needs to do
it through belief but does the exact
same thing.
Do you think that that is somehow still
an inherent problem with,
with the proper,
not the proper way to be a human,
but just well,
what's the problem then if somebody does
that?
Uh,
well there,
there are two to two issues with that.
One is what's the problem?
Does that cause a problem with your
relationship to somebody?
So I have a friend who's,
not only is he a hardcore Christian,
he writes children's books trying to
indoctrinate people into Christian.
Phil Vischer,
the guy from veggies,
Veggie Tales,
just be on very good friend of mine,
Alex and such.
So this shows you can be friends with
some you can and,
and I've confided in her about things
and I trust him and I have told him in
no uncertain terms,
I think he's harboring a,
not a misconception,
but delusion about the nature of
reality.
And we've had a civil talk,
no one threw fisticuffs Nolan.
We talk about that in the context of our
friendship,
but that wasn't sufficient for him to
end the Pie.
Never had any idea where we were talking
about the side that wasn't sufficient
for him to withdraw from the friendship
and the friendship.
And that's a core belief.
I mean that's an antithetical belief to
what I've devoted my professional life
is to helping people think clearly and
critically and overthrow Dogma and an
ideology and morally motivated
reasoning.
But I think the problem,
the problem with that is it depends on
what you want to have,
what your relationship to truth wants
to,
what you think it should be.
There would be something to me if,
if somebody was friends with me and a
genuine friend in a virtuous friend,
only because they feared that if they
would not do that,
they would go to hell.
There would be something suspect in that
for me.
But what or who wasn't that?
What if they just,
they just had some belief that,
you know what I mean?
Like whatever it is.
Or they just had some belief that Karma
prove our car.
Right.
Okay.
Karma is a great,
yeah.
So they just believed in Karma.
What they're going to put out there is
going to come back to them because of
that they become the virtuous type of
person that you aspire to be.
But it's a,
it's a,
it's a great question.
I think I've shifted my stance on that
over the years,
but I guess I'm having trouble with the
question because I don't really think
someone can truly be virtuous if they
harbor beliefs based on a faulty
epistemology.
Right.
So we could sort of get lost,
but my definition of virtue then,
let's just say that's the case.
Uh,
would the world would be better off in
human flourishing,
would be contributed to if more people
had this false belief of view than if we
resorted to this hub Sian state?
Um,
yeah.
I,
I guess the problem would be,
uh,
if they alone believe that and didn't
try to institutionalize that,
I think it would be,
it would be less of a problem than I
would have said even two or three years
ago.
Yeah.
And I think perhaps,
and I'll watch the video again myself,
I think you might've answered that a
little bit differently and I'm,
which shows a flexible mind.
Do you ever fear that as,
as a public person,
you say things,
you tweet,
things you do,
interviews,
you go on podcasts,
all those things that people are gonna
be like,
ah,
you see he two years ago he said
something else and it's like,
they just want to get you so,
so that,
that should what we really need to
understand.
Yeah.
So that should be a virtue.
It should be a virtue that you change
your mind.
I will admit it's hard for me to admit,
but it's true.
It's so difficult when you're constantly
under attack and constantly under siege
to say it's,
it's far more difficult.
Not only to say I made a mistake,
but like,
look,
I really thought about this and then you
get,
that's why I've stopped reading my
twitter mentions or facebook and none of
it,
I don't read any of it anymore because
it's just so filled with hate and rage.
And even if you look at the terms we
use,
the moral valence to terms have like
flip flopping,
flip flopping is a negative thing.
Like you change your mind,
but you should change your mind if your
commander in chief and the situation on
the ground changes,
you didn't have access to that.
Oh,
he flip flop about troops in Iraq or
bunk Guantanamo.
Well,
we live in a dynamic world where things
are in flux and they change.
But I have,
I have found,
I have definitely found that being that
sort of person who's not willing to
change my mind,
but the open open admission of that on
twitter or facebook has become more
difficult as people ramp up their
personal slanders and attacks.
Yeah.
So I'm,
I'm very aware of that,
that I'm dying to talk to you about
this.
Yeah.
Diana talked to you about what's been
going on with you.
I've had some strange things going on.
We'll get there in just one second.
You also had another that sort of attack
on you who sort of similar to what I had
on me,
but that,
but I think you're really onto something
there that I don't think it's,
if someone,
you know,
sometimes people will say,
well,
you said this three years ago,
I,
you used to believe this.
They'll look at some of my tweets when I
was a far left progressive.
Yeah.
And look what used to make fun of white
people for this.
And I go,
yeah,
you're not proving me.
What are you trying to prove?
You're proving that yes,
I evolved.
He's changed your mind and you say,
wow,
this guy had tooken information and as a
result isn't there,
but you're rational people too.
That's what,
right.
That's what you're supposed to do.
But you're also right about the,
the other point,
which is that when you're under attack
from people,
when you feel like everything you're
going to say is that then you stop
having those nice moments of mayor
culpas contrition.
Yeah.
You know what else you stop doing,
which is interesting.
You stop asking questions and,
and you might ask the questions
yourself,
but you,
you don't want to articulate those
questions or you don't want to
articulate those rebuttals because you
don't,
you really don't want to receive 500
emails and shift through all of the
telling you you're a shithead and you
should go die and kill yourself and
people write in your name and the walls
is a Nazi.
They see you stopped doing that.
I mean,
like give an example.
I was this film I was in with Michael
Shermer reasons to believe,
and I made a comment about a pussy hats.
These people having pussy ass and,
and it makes it look like we,
this is not the image you want to
portray.
And someone,
I got an unbelievable amount of,
of,
uh,
just crazy target about that.
But one of the things I thought was,
I almost said I came so close to saying,
do you think Martin Luther King would
have been more respected or less
respected if he had a pussy hat on?
I mean,
it would've been the perfect thing to
say,
but I didn't say it because I didn't
want hundreds of emails and tweets about
me being a racist.
So I think we're in a precarious
situation right now.
And I think Sam is getting this crazy
amounts,
asking questions,
opening conversations.
We need to have those conversations.
We need,
I need
to ask those questions.
You're talking about Sam Harris just,
yeah,
Sam Ash,
uh,
had Charles Murray on even Gary Tobbs,
the guy who the,
the anti sugar guy.
So what do you do then if you were in my
position or in Santa this position when
I see some articles written about
balance and,
well,
Ruben talked to this guy or this guy or
this gal and they think this and Ruben
didn't ask them this and all this stuff.
So Sam gets to this too,
by the way.
I mean,
vox did a really hatchet job.
It misrepresents what him and Charles
Murray talked about,
how long a hit pieces and write and and
slate.
Just wrote something about you were
going to talk about the conceptual penis
shortly and what happened with with
salon,
but all of those things they add up to
us not having any more conversation
because at some point it's just like,
all right,
well then I'll just yet
I'll just talk to,
it's not that I'll talk to people that I
agree with.
I'll just talk to people who say
nothing.
That's right.
Because then I've completely insulated
myself.
Right,
and no,
it'll really show.
So this is,
this is,
I think what we need to do.
I think we need to figure out everybody,
James Lindsey actually gave me this idea
and I think he's absolutely right,
a coauthor of the conceptual penis,
a social contract.
We need to figure out whose voice
matters.
Certain people matter and in general
this hate and vitriol comes from the
least accomplished people who in need.
There's a really nice niche in frame to
talk about this there.
They viewed,
there's kind of an oversimplified but,
but their slaves,
their situation,
reality is their slaves and they
discharge these primal urges on people.
It's like the Australians have this term
tall poppy syndrome.
When it's something gross,
hi,
you just cut it down.
So as Ruben grows and subscribers and
that's where if I could just cut reuben
down,
you know,
fuck them.
It's kind of that Nazi white supremacy,
homophobia.
So we gay marriage you Nazi homophobe
right?
I know it's overwhelming,
but we have to figure out whose voices
matter and then we need to,
we need to have those friendships,
a virtue.
So when people come to us and say
something,
we can really listen.
But the way to not do it is to look at,
as you've said repeatedly to look at an
egg on twitter.
It's probably a 12 year old in their
basement.
We just can't take those voices
seriously.
All right.
So sort of couched around everything
we're talking about so far is,
is sort of good and evil.
That tactics that some people use to be
involved in a conversation and the
motives that we have,
whether it be because you're a believer
or a nonbeliever,
anything else.
I've come to a place where I think right
now in 2017 we're in a strange spot
where the fascinating the institutions
that used to help us keep some of this
stuff in the lanes.
What,
what is acceptable,
what's not acceptable,
what's right and wrong,
what's real and not real.
Whether it's true or not,
that these institutions are crumbling.
And by that I mean that media is
crumbling.
Our political institutions seem to be
crying gimmick institution.
So that's the one I really want to get
into with you.
Um,
all of these things are starting to
crumble.
It's partly because information has
changed so much.
I would argue that even worse than
crumble,
but what you would say they're,
they're decimated already.
No,
no.
I would argue that the academy,
certain sections of the Academy of the
sciences I think are doing very,
very well.
The humanities are in shambles.
Certain departments,
anything tainted by Postmodernism,
particularly gender studies,
the conceptual penis.
Okay.
Let's pause for a sec.
Let's just go to the conceptual penis as
a social construct.
As a social construct,
right?
You wrote a hoax paper with James
Lindsey,
right?
And you got this publish and we thought
it was extremely funny.
I mean,
I read it,
it,
it's,
it's jaw droppingly ridiculous and
argued for climate change,
uh,
being responsible.
The conceptual penis.
Yeah.
And I thought it was really,
it was a satire,
sort of the main takeaway of it is that
the penis is not really a real thing.
It's just this sort of a morphis idea.
And we threw in a lot of moral jargon.
We throw in what we appeal to their
moral sensibilities.
Okay.
So why Pete,
you're an academic.
Why would you write a hoax paper?
Why would you mark the very institutions
of which you are?
Because I think that there are
departments in the universities that are
making a mockery of our institutions.
So when you said crumbling,
I don't think that's right.
Ah,
that's not the word.
I would have used other words.
It's accurate in a sense.
But these people are fabricating not
only their own knowledge bases,
they're writing things in journals that
they then site that becomes knowledge.
They have their manufacturing ideas that
are totally untethered to reality.
This is how crazy this is.
So,
so look,
I'm going to explain it.
I'm gonna try explaining this.
You reel me in if this is unclear,
but this is idea is so crazy that
anybody listening to this exam that
can't possibly like this,
this can't possibly be true.
So this is the idea and then I'm going
to give you,
you're asking me what belief I'm going
to give you an analog and theology.
Okay.
So what these people do is that they
have moral intuitions based upon is
thought basically.
I'll get to that in a second.
So what they do to justify this is they
manufacture their own epistemology,
their own way to know that justifies the
conclusions that they have.
So then they can go out and become
activists.
Now,
quick detour.
Yeah.
One of the,
hmm.
Biggest problems facing the left right
now is anybody who calls out a bad idea
is viewed as somebody on the right.
We've got to stop that.
I know a little something about,
you know,
a little something about this.
Yeah,
a lot about this.
So let's,
I'm going to give you an analogy in
theology.
So this Guy Alvin Plantinga,
he's a Christian philosopher.
So he has these beliefs,
these,
they're actually more than that.
Their claims about reality and about
Jesus being the son of God.
So he realizes that there's no evidence
they can take them there usually.
So what does he do?
He manufactured his own epistemology.
He said,
well,
you know,
we're going to say that there's this
thing called the God center and the God
center.
Some people have it and it allows you to
just as I apprehend the color red,
so to do I apprehend God.
So he makes an epistemology to justify
these insane claims about the nature of
reality.
So just as he has done that
critical theory is that epistemology
that is used,
and I can explain that is complex.
I'm afraid we're gonna lose people.
We got a lot of terms we've got to throw
out.
It's very complicated.
But what I would like to attempt to do
in this segment is to link the madness
on campuses right now to the
intellectual engines driving that
madness.
And the make no mistake about it.
These departments tainted by
postmodernism are absolutely filled with
zealots and morally motivated.
Either ideologues,
I'll do a little catch up so that in
case anyone's missing anything.
So first let's,
let's talk about what is postmodernism.
I know,
most knows that,
but let's just,
let's just do a couple of definitions.
Quicks okay,
so let's do the definition.
So,
okay,
so the Frankfurt,
Frankfurt school has this idea of,
well that's even,
go back for it.
Let's go back to Karl Marx.
Karl Marx was a philosopher.
Ooh,
here's a bonus question.
Why did Hitler hate call marks?
I feel like there's a good punchline.
Well,
it's not a joke.
It's actually true cause he was a Jew.
Jews touched where,
but otherwise they are great guy.
okay.
So,
so mark's Marxist economics and these
people aren't Marxists.
They're more Marxian would be a better
term marks.
Economics looks at the world in terms of
economical pressure,
their oppressor classes,
et cetera.
So they have,
and then we'll get to the idea of
postmodern postmodernism.
Very,
it's as simple and complicated should
they've taken this idea of these Marxian
notions of oppressor classes and looked
at them in terms of gender and race and
for example,
the patriarchy.
And then they have hierarchically
prioritized people within that list.
So the Patriarchy is white,
heterosexual,
cisgendered,
which is a thing males.
And they want it at the top of this.
We're a bank.
I am.
Absolutely.
But that's the other thing they do just
like religion,
they have their own defense mechanisms
and that's what they say.
Well you can't criticize it because
you're a CIS gendered,
white,
heterosexual male and and is the
ultimate irony of this.
That is prejudice.
That is prejudging.
Ah,
okay.
I,
I then sit here and go,
wait a minute.
Okay.
Aigner but cozy in a white,
straight CIS gendered male.
So we judge you based on your immutable
characteristic.
Okay.
So this is indispensable to talk about.
So you are using words based upon
normal,
ordinary definition.
I'll give you an example some more.
It's like,
so when you use racism,
it's the way I use most people who
aren't in,
haven't been indoctrinated by gender
studies and the postmodern left.
It's the idea that you do not judge
people particularly negatively,
but you don't make judgments about
people based upon an immutable
characteristic like their skin color.
But they've changed that definition to
make it systemic racism.
They've changed that definite definition
to put in,
um,
a power vector,
that hierarchical power vector that only
flows one way.
So for example,
and this blacks cannot be racist whites,
so they have snuck,
it's very sneaky.
They've taken a normal word,
added a,
a,
a moral component to it and change the
definition of a word.
It,
it,
you know,
here's some,
if I may give you some more examples,
like,
um,
equality.
Equality is a good thing,
but they've shifted from a quality to
equity.
Now what does equity mean?
Equity means where we need a certain
number of people,
representative of the general population
of 17% African Americans.
We need to have 17% but the problem is
that that,
that they also want to take in to
account historical discrimination and a
kind of reparations for that.
So those numbers are even higher.
So it's,
I think it can be summarized in Ruth
Bader Ginsburg's quip or joke or
whatever it is.
How many few females,
Supreme Court justices do you think
there should be nine.
So it's not just right,
it's not just that we want equal
representation,
we want more because of past injustices.
Go ahead.
Because this is this get,
we got to talk about deconstruction.
We got to talk about violence.
We can talk about why all these things.
When you understand them from this
mindset,
they're all coming from the same school
of thought effected by critical theory.
That's why the most inelegant,
let's define critical theory.
Yeah.
So critical theory is this idea that
you,
um,
that traditional power dynamics and
traditional,
and this is oversimplified,
but it's a general idea from which we
can have a starting point for a
conversation.
See,
that's again,
I thought to myself,
I'm going to get 500 emails and just
trying to,
and it makes me again,
it,
it makes me self sensor and then I'm
like come on.
Yeah,
okay.
That's a real,
that's a real,
I don't want to get lost in that.
That is a real thing.
I mean I find it for myself to know is I
tried to talk broadly about things
because I want to communicate big ideas
and hopefully people will then read some
books or watched some other videos or
follow some other people on twitter or
whatever.
And then even if you talk about,
well he,
he,
yeah,
he wept over that.
Right?
Or he didn't know that.
So why didn't you talk about the
Frankfurt school like quick you didn't
mention Horkheimer wants,
are doing over.
All these guys are let guys know.
And you know,
just,
you just get to a point where all of
that stuff just centering essentially.
It just,
it's not dementia is the message.
It's not good for you.
It's not good for conversations.
It's not good for,
okay.
So anyway,
that's why I mentioned the think was
efficient and I think that was an
acquisition right now if you think for
yourself and you are not afraid to buck
the trend,
they will come to get you.
It's exactly,
we're talking about so critical theory.
So it's the idea
that um,
the,
it's basically a Marxist idea.
It's the idea that there are these
entrenched power structures and
entrenched power dynamics.
And one of the things that we need to do
is we need to recognize these and then
we need to overthrow the,
we need to deconstruct these traditional
hierarchies to make society more.
That's the thing.
More equitable,
more fair,
more what did it,
what is it?
It's complicated.
So these kids protesting at evergreen or
have,
they don't just x Niello just get this
idea that they just gonna it just does
it.
No,
they get this.
These are coming out of specific
departments in the university and when
they're asked,
why do you do this?
So what is this?
They they talk,
well my professor said this and then
this is the,
the insane part that gets back to the
conceptual penis again.
That these people have their own lines
of literature.
That is the,
these are intellectual cesspools to have
that's going to be talking about,
no,
so they have their tags that they have
manufactured what they think.
That's why they have to like with
cultural appropriation,
they have to import ideas like power
because it isn't it,
the whole thing is made up.
It's completely fabricated because they
want to use,
they want to overthrow these traditional
hierarchies.
So these kids get this idea from their
professors who then get promoted and
tenure because they publish in journals
and their stuff is almost never cited by
anybody.
But yet that's how you rise up.
And then what happens is you have a
whole Canon of knowledge and you go out
and teach people and then you have
diversity training and,
and the,
the shame of this whole thing is that
there is legitimacy to white power.
There is legitimacy to some of this
stuff,
but the way that it's metastasized
almost doesn't allow any kind of
liberation.
It does almost the exact opposite of
what they want to do because it gets you
people like trump.
But one more thing I would say.
Yeah,
but,
but then what happens is it goes to
colleges of education and then they
start teaching.
And I think I told you my son has in his
geography has geography,
civics.
I can't remember.
I'm looking at stuff he doesn't,
they've never even opened a map.
They've never opened a map.
They've never in civics class,
how many Supreme Court justices?
Legislative branch,
how many said none of that stuff.
But he knows everything about the black
panthers.
But he knows everything about the civil
rights.
The civil rights movement is extremely
important.
Wonderful stuff.
But it should not.
We need to look,
I'm looking at him at,
we need kids need to know what countries
above Canada.
Anyway,
all of this stuff gets back to certain
departments in the university that are
pumping out nonsense that are
indoctrinating people and exactly like a
religion,
they have their own defensive structures
there.
You know,
being offended as the new thing I
inclusion is another word that they've
changed the meaning of.
So there was a direct line between is
this company,
is this clear so far?
I'm with you to me.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's a judge with the audience.
So cause if it's not clear,
something needs to be unpacked.
So they want to overthrow these
traditional and they've manufactured
their own base of scholarship to do so.
So how would you,
that's why it's worse than crumbling
because at least if something crumbles,
something worse didn't take its place.
Like if in a lot like it's like a having
an alarm clock that rings randomly.
So it's worse than just having an alarm
clock that doesn't work.
It's,
they're pumping out fabricated nonsense.
It's totally untethered to reality in
the moment you call these people out on
it.
They don't believe in dialogue in any
way they deal.
They'll slander you.
The write your name on the bathroom
wall,
they'll scream at you.
So the only thing to do is you've got to
hoax some you,
you,
you got to have a nontraditional way to
deal with people who are so
fundamentally irrational that they're
going to have a conversation and that
led you to writing this hoax and turning
this thing on its head.
All right there,
there was so much there I want to get
to.
So first of all,
what's the connection with the religious
mind that people have?
Wonderful,
this strikes me as the new religion
politics but,
but this leftist postmodern marks and
stuff that this is the new religion.
They,
they mon hundred bakemark everyone else
for their beliefs,
but they have a belief that is so
tethered to their own being that if you
challenge it in any way they outcome,
well they'll hate you.
But they'll also outkast anyone 100%
correct.
And so what do you say about that?
So that is an awesome question.
So Lindsay and I wrote him on every now
and wrote and wrote a paper again,
uh,
privileges the original sin for the
left.
So,
but there is one fundamental difference.
You're,
you're having schermer and prager come
into the studio and debate and it's
going to be civilized.
No one's going to punch each other.
They have fundamental,
actually very fundamental,
just moral disagreements.
And one of them prager blends that you
cannot have morality without God.
And shermer believes the complete
opposite.
So this is powerful stuff,
right?
They've agreed and they're going to have
a dialogue about that.
And I'm not going to score,
I don't know if it's a debate.
I,
I don't really,
I'm not a fan of Beta.
Having a conversation is much better.
But so,
so you have the same mechanisms in the,
in this new secular religion,
you have privilege,
which is a type of original sin.
You have blasphemy laws,
which are political correctness.
We're really clear that.
So would you say the privileges,
the originals,
and that's like saying Jesus died for
your sins,
basically.
Like you're,
if you were born white and especially
CIS gendered heterosexual,
that Shit that you are,
that you are the,
there's nothing you can ditch.
Yeah.
To.
And this is the part that except bow,
this is the part that's the mind blow.
And this is the part that makes me
unbelievably sympathetic to Christians
in particular as opposed to other
religions.
That's really changed my mind
significantly.
Christians have a redemption narrative.
These people have no redemption
narrative.
If you're a privileged,
that's it.
You're fucked.
Like you,
there is no redemption for you.
You can bow down for us.
Yeah.
So there,
there's something about being able to be
redeemed that these people don't have.
And that's why you see these vitriolic
attacks.
They're merciless on other people on the
left eating other people on the left,
the old,
the old bras,
you know,
the snake that eats itself.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so it is a new secular religion and they
have,
maybe we have modules in our brain,
I don't know.
And maybe it's covariant there with
culture.
There are things in the culture and act
in our brain.
And we have the same thing we have in
Jonathan hightest.
It talked about three of purity versus
saying to maybe we have,
you know,
ways of interpreting reality,
but make no mistake,
this is a secular religion.
And when you call out the emperor having
no clothes,
you dad is that you have committed,
you are in trouble.
Right.
Which I think has a bit to do have the,
the recent hatchet jobs that have been
done on me and you,
so sleep basically wrote a piece about
you after this whole thing,
right?
And it really was kind of strong madding
what you did,
but the attacks were also kind of
personal.
And that's
always is an interesting,
you know,
in salon goes after me or you asleep
cause after me or you or Sam,
whoever Harris,
who,
wherever they go after there was a kind
of Pr Animus.
There's a kind of personal attack that
is not just a,
an engagement of the,
hey look,
you know,
you did this,
this is why it's not right.
Right,
right.
You know it's not,
oh yeah,
maybe it was funny,
but you're wrong about this and here's
why.
Oh,
deeply personal attack on someone.
So I called them on the phone.
I think I emailed them at least one toy
few times and I said,
look,
you guys wrote this about me.
I would like an opportunity to respond
to this.
Nothing.
Then I went on twitter and I said,
hey,
can I please have an opportunity to
just,
well you know he won't sleep.
I don't know the exact wording was but
can I,
I'd like an opportunity.
Nothing.
I would like an arbitrary,
I don't know.
Maybe that's a new thing in journalism.
Like you just write hit pieces on
someone and then you don't give him an
office.
I think Hayes,
I think it is.
I think what's starting to happen is
that because journal isn't,
because mainstream journalism is
crumbling.
Yeah.
I still use that,
that adjective there and,
and nobody cares about CNN anymore.
Right.
And even the New York Times I think has,
has gone in a really terrible direction
cause they love a lot of the ideas that
you're talking about.
But since the institutions are
crumbling,
well now everybody just picks their
website that they can try.
Those websites are funded by all sorts
of different things.
And if you've got an editor who has
bought in to your postmodern bullshit in
this case,
well you know,
you can say whatever the hell you want
about Peter,
Dave,
or whoever else and you're going to get
backing.
So for this whole craziness that
happened with me and mother Jones says
truth,
truth has been removed from that.
Right,
right.
Which has been removed from that and to,
for them for this editor.
So they,
the title of the thing was about the,
the new extremist further to the right.
We have to talk about that.
So we have to talk about that.
I have to be out of your mind or,
or,
or just a lie are of the highest order
to think that of me.
You can,
yeah.
You can criticize me for all you want.
I,
I address criticism.
I hear if people think I don't ask the
right,
it's not just that he's a terrible
journalist.
He has a religious mindset.
Like,
this is a religion to these people.
So that,
so that's the interesting thing.
So then I went on the full on,
I mean I was like,
you know what?
You picked the wrong person to fuck
with.
Right.
And I went on the absolute attack.
I was defended publicly by you Brogan
and a whole slew of other people to the
tens of thousands of retweets and things
of that.
And then V to I guess two days ago,
he was writing about how noah,
he doesn't believe I'm an extremist,
but he doesn't,
you know,
there's no public correction.
They do slight things at the end of the
article that no one's gonna ever see
wikipedia that is still run with the
real thing.
Exactly.
Goes,
I tagged the editor,
this woman,
Clara Jeffery and all of the,
in all the tweets,
she never responds.
She's never gotten this much twitter
attraction,
but they don't feel a need to because
they know that their monster is just
going to keep moving forward.
And that's what I'm trying to figure out
the antidote.
So just to be clear,
you and so what did he say about your
show?
The title and you can look at it.
Maybe it still is pinned tweet right now
though I suspect he's either deleted it
or removed it all together was something
about the rise of the new extremism or
the newest extremists that are further
to the right than Breitbart.
Then he includes me in that where he
refers to me as far right,
right.
Then eventually change that to just
write which the right left thing doesn't
even make any sense anymore.
I can put all that aside.
As I mentioned at the top,
Forbes called this a conservative show
last week.
I've said to you,
I think you were the first one I ever
said it to,
that defending my liberal principles is
becoming a conservative position.
So all of these labels are starting to
make no sense and that's just part of
the what's happened here and that sort
of thing.
So a couple of things here.
If you had an itemized checklist,
if you could just write your beliefs
down and you check you and I would both
overwhelmingly fall into the liberal
camp,
not the left camp.
Right.
And that's why I've been saying liberal
is not left.
Dad is a crane.
It's from state complaint.
But just to be clear for you,
so without naming the person who wrote
the article,
the guy who wrote the article that would
make,
yeah,
Josh Harkinson.
Okay.
Is Josh invited on your show?
Yeah,
I invited him immediately.
I said No.
Is he still invited on your show?
And he wrote something started like
first I said,
come on my show,
I'll give you the first 10 minutes
without talking.
He didn't respond to that.
Then today,
finally days later I respond to it again
and say,
or the day we're taping,
this is off of when we're airing it.
But today I wrote,
you know,
will you come on the show?
You Hack.
So then I was being a little more heavy
handed and you're old.
I won't come on cause you called me a
name.
I mean how many wouldn't come?
So the hack thing was just an excuse,
just to be completely clear.
You said I was going to sit here for 10
minutes or so.
You'd come on,
you can sit here and 10 minutes I will
sit here and I wasn't anything outside
of the editor too,
by the way.
She's welcome to come on and all that.
But,
but in an odd way,
maybe that,
and someone pointed this out to me on
twitter,
one of the strange,
odd,
same voices said,
Dave,
that was to be the worst thing you could
do.
Because what you're doing is you're
encouraging more people to do things
like urging people to say crazy things
about you.
You then get in a huff puff and you
gotta defend yourself and now what's the
next thing?
Now you got to,
you got to sit and take it on your own
show,
which is so completely against the ideas
that you care about.
Like I don't want my life to be that.
You know what I mean?
And that's why my left to me that
either.
Yeah.
So it's a,
it's an odd punish.
It is.
And yet you don't want to just ignore
it.
It's against human nature to be attacked
and to just sit down and take.
That's why we talked before about you
have to figure out whose voices matter.
Yeah.
And,
and I mean I don't know anything about
this guy,
but does his voice mattered to you?
I mean is this guy's opinion no hit,
he's utterly irrelevant to me.
But he wrote a piece in a publication
that has saw so,
so the publication has some relevance.
And by the way,
this guy,
as I mentioned at the top also,
he was one of 40 people that the
Virginia Gop Baseball Games shooter
followed.
So we know that that guy was,
was riled up by a lot of the political
stuff he was reading.
Cause you could just look at his
facebook and all that to see that and
how much he hated Republicans,
whatever.
So if you're calling me an extremist
there,
there's a cost now that ideas and
intentions matter,
which is why I think you can attack the
hell out of ideas and you and you not
can,
you should,
but there's a need.
You should be instigating violence and,
and there in lies the rub.
How do you feel now about all this now
that it's been a day behind you and him?
Did you,
do you feel angry when it happened on
Friday?
I was,
I was livid.
I was in New York City and I was walking
in the middle of Time Square.
So I'm in Times Square,
the craziest place on earth.
Like,
you know,
stimulation via bananas and whatever,
and I'm just flicking off twitter and
I'm calling people and like I'm going to
destroy them and everything else.
And uh,
you know,
some people said to me,
this is the very definition of libel
because it's the mantras really untrue.
He's attacking your income source
because of the reference to Patriot on
all these other things.
I don't want to sue the guy,
uh,
by,
by the way,
I've been on the record as saying I am
for libel and I'm a free speech
absolutist,
but there are laws that we have related
to liable.
That's a secondary thing.
Uh,
but then on,
on Monday,
uh,
when it calmed down,
when I got home from New York on Sunday
night,
you know this cause you're,
you're in my house right now.
I came home and my dog was staggering
around Emma.
She's 13.
I love,
love,
love this dog with every fiber of my
being.
She uh,
she was a rescue from Hurricane Katrina.
I've had her for 11 years and she was
staggering and she was having trouble
standing and she looked confused and her
eyes are darting around and then I spent
the night and we had to bring her as she
stayed at the,
at the animal hospital over night.
We just got her back today and she has
some issues that we're hopefully going
can work on,
but it completely put everything in
perspective.
That animal is more important to me than
this bullshit.
Right.
Without question.
It doesn't mean I'm not going to get
riled up.
But my love of this animal farts,
what we talked about before about
relationships in,
and you have really,
I have two too,
create a crazy dogs.
But those relationships matter and in
that sense they,
they not superseded,
not override,
but it made you refocus on what
mattered.
Like you could be doing all this stuff
like that thing and private Ryan,
that scene where the guy's like saying,
are we going to do this?
We this and he gets a bullet in the
head.
You know,
like now you have a sick animal,
you know,
like your,
your dog is sick and you love your dog.
And I dunno,
I guess it's interesting.
I don't know whether or not having him
on would be your mistake or not because
it would encourage other people to do
the same thing.
Yeah.
Well I know it would because it's a
feeding frenzy.
We know how these guys operate.
We've seen this before with many things
in college.
Yeah.
What do you think his motivation was?
I mean,
I know you can't,
what is the motivation?
Because I believe that it's exactly what
you're talking about,
that it's this religious,
uh,
you were it,
what was the word you use there?
Was this religious,
quasi religious or moral motivated?
A secular religion.
Security.
Really?
Yeah.
It's this secular religion that they so
believe.
So I veered off the path for these guys.
It doesn't matter that I'm gay,
married,
doesn't matter that I'm pro pot.
It doesn't matter that I'm pro choice.
It doesn't matter that I'm for
euthanasia to check us all the way down.
And one side is religious and this is
why I talk about the left more because
on the right,
even though they know all of those
things,
I still get invited places.
I get put on prager u videos.
I get invited to college kids that want
to talk to me.
They put aside all the different,
I was at a libertarian,
uh,
students for liberty thing.
I said,
I'm for single payer healthcare.
Libertarians don't like that.
They booed me,
but then laughed.
We laughed about it and I kind of mock
them for boomi.
Guys were the tolerant ones on guys and
they got it.
I don't get any invites the other way.
So that's why I think that phrase is so
perfect because this is the new
religion.
It is the new religion.
Why do you think you don't get msnbc
doesn't have you on,
I don't know.
I can't beg him.
I was on Fox last week.
Greg Gutfeld,
which I think is a great guy.
He was going to come on in here really
doing good stuff.
We disagree on some stuff.
Okay.
Big Dam up,
but I can't beg them.
Why does,
why does Fox put on Ion and MSNBC?
Does he see that?
I mean,
they've got such a wonderful question
that demand that we should demand
answers to that.
Did you see last week that the hearings
last week a hawk,
what's his name?
The actor that plays Hulk?
Uh,
the actor that Plays Hall Company helped
me here.
Mark refollow.
Oh yeah.
He said,
the thing about,
you know,
MSNBC is hiring these white
conservatives.
And it's so interesting because he's
judging people's political opinions on
their skin color number one.
Now he's a white guy who plays a green
guy so that there's something occurring.
You know,
you must,
as a philosophy professor mustard up,
there's gotta be some deep shit there.
But even putting that aside,
if they started hiring a bunch of black
conservatives,
he wouldn't be happy about that either
because he would accuse them of being
uncle toms or something.
We can party.
It's like Clarence Thomas,
you know,
we need more Supreme Court justices
there a bike too.
Like would you rather have more
Clarence Thomas is on the Supreme Court
or would you rather have more white
liberals on the Supreme Court?
So what do you think is the antidote to
this?
Because I've been trying to push the
ideas of classical liberalism.
As you know,
I believe that the individual is the
only antidote to this.
If you relentlessly stand for the
individual,
you will always stand for our
differences.
You will always be tolerant of our
differences because you will realize
that your different than the next guy.
You won't look at somebody and prejudge
them based on color or say I have to
treat them like are some animal because
they have this level of uh,
oppression where the other that,
okay,
so you put,
you put your finger on the problem.
So let's talk about the opposite
problem.
Intersectionality is the problem.
We haven't talked about that,
but that there is grievance jockeying.
Gad said the oppression,
Olympics,
etc.
We we need the opposite of Internet
intersectionality and we need union
[inaudible] and there's a line of
literature called a superordinate
identities.
So let's unpack that real quick.
Have you seen the Heineken commercial?
Yes.
It's incredible.
It's amazing.
It's,
it's everything that I've tried to do
here.
Okay,
so that's what we need.
We don't need,
can you just lay it out real quick for
you?
We'll lay out the heineken cholesterol.
They just basically get people together
who you'd think have nothing to do with
each other or should we write political
enemies or personal enemies and they sit
down over a drink and do it and they do
it well then they,
they,
they're not sex.
No,
no.
They do some task,
right.
There's some hard task and then at the
end they say,
do you want to have a beer?
And they say,
and then they talk as an example of a,
of,
of a union ality as opposed to
intersectionality.
We're not grieving.
We're not trying to find out who has the
most strikes against them,
who's the most depressed and then they
get the most,
um,
they get the rights to talk.
The blm,
uh,
can,
over over can talk to the pride Martin
March or what have you,
what we need to do is,
or the shooting in Virginia right now,
we need to appeal to larger identities
and we need to coalition build and I see
the left over and over again continuing
to dig down in identity politics,
continuing to,
uh,
use intersectionality to find the most
marginalized and oppressed groups and
then to attempt to change either the
nature of words either or,
and the structure of the rule sets and
our institutions to privilege these
folks.
John Rawls had this whole thing,
salt,
but I think superordinate identities,
finding identities and things that we
have in common and working to build
coalitions and I,
and I think if we,
if the left continues to do that,
we'll either get another four years of
trump or that other lunatic pants.
It,
right.
It's,
we need to build identities.
It's funny that you describe it that way
because you're,
you're talking about postmodernism,
you're talking about cultural,
Marxism,
all this stuff.
And yet so people will go,
well Pete,
Pete must be right.
It must be on the right.
It must be some sort of evil
conservative or whatever.
And yet you're not.
No,
and I do more I think,
by the way,
I don't want to use conservative.
As I said this chapter,
I don't want to use it as a pejorative.
I mean,
so that's the thing I don't feel at
home.
I no longer,
and maybe it's cause I'm oddly situated
there,
that's another word they love.
I'm oddly situated in the academy and
Portland new,
which is very left to center anyway.
Even though the overwhelming majority of
my beliefs I would call self identify as
a classical liberal.
I no longer feel at home with anything
to do with things that are even broadly
the left.
And you and other people have called for
the new center.
I think that might be what we need.
I certainly don't feel at home in the
right.
And again,
in terms of that checklist of beliefs
they have.
So I feel that I'm efficient cause I
kind of feel like when I lived in
Albuquerque I feel that I'm wandering,
not wondering.
I feel that I've,
I don't have a home and I don't feel
comfortable anywhere,
but one of the consequences of not
feeling comfortable is when you meet
people who share those beliefs,
you have a kind of ideological kinship.
You have a kind of,
wow,
we're really on the out chair right
there.
We're,
we're really trying to figure this out.
We're really trying to make some,
we try to live a good life.
We're trying to be decent.
People were trying to make decisions on
the base of evidence and yeah,
we changed our minds and,
but we're not at home and the right,
we're not at home on the left were being
excoriated on the,
on the left for calling out,
never make calling out somebody
bullshit,
a right wing thing.
The moment you've done that,
you're,
you've become a farce,
a caricature of yourself.
It's a farce.
You know,
it's so interesting you've hit on so
many things because I love what we're
doing here because it's,
we're talking about the sort of these
broad issues,
but then also how they are directly
related to us as people and that's what
I think really matters.
And even,
you know,
just a week ago or so,
and I think it was in Philadelphia,
they unveiled their new gay pride
rainbow flag,
but now it has a black and brown color
bar,
you know,
to new color bars to represent people of
color.
And this is the height of absurdity.
The rainbow flag represented all gay
people,
White Gay people,
Asian Gay people,
Muslim gay people,
the Jewish gay people,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
There was no racial connotation to it.
And the gay community,
at least from what I can tell,
this is pretty good on,
on most race issues you see more couples
I think that are racially different or
diverse or all that stuff.
But now because they had to bow to
whatever that,
I don't know if it was directly related
to black lives matter or whatever,
but because they had to bow to them,
they've literally ruined the rainbow.
The rainbow is we know what the rainbow
is now they're telling us the rainbow is
inherently part of the patriarchy or
you're a racist.
There anything,
I didn't end up but,
but here's the personal part.
So I thought all of this,
obviously I don't think I'm blowing
anyone's mind when I say this.
They understand what I think.
But I didn't even want to tweet about it
cause I didn't even feel like getting
involved on this one.
It's like I got to pick my battles and
if I was gonna say,
well,
someone's using you're racist.
You don't want a black bar and a brown
bar on that.
But my point would be there was no
racial kind of tissue.
You're now making it racist and guess
what?
Somebody's years from now he's going to
have some other thing that they want to
put on there and they're going to have
to make sure they're more oppressive
than you.
And this is the endless snake eating
itself.
Something just within that,
you know,
I'm taking about emily being sick.
I think that's one of the things that
people don't see when they attack you.
people don't like.
You're just a guy living in your life.
You've got a dog,
you've got a husband you're trying to
make through the day,
like everybody else.
And I think people need to take a step
back and realize that we're actually
people like Dave Rubin is a guy and he's
a good guy and he likes Heineken or,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
I'm a Ford Guy.
More footwear,
we're flawed people.
And if you have a a problem with
somebody,
it's much better.
And it's not necessarily the tone of the
criticism.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I feel,
I feel weird saying,
well,
I to start doing attack,
Dave Rubin,
what?
I don't think,
you're not saying don't attack me.
I want to do whatever they want to do
anyway.
But I think that you would get more
mileage and more attention if those
criticisms were devoid of personal
attacks.
And you said,
Reuben said this,
this is why I think it's wrong and you
lay it out.
Well,
that's what I said before when people
would attack me and said,
well,
Dave,
you didn't ask this question.
Are you asked the question the wrong way
or you you,
you know my policy on interviewing as I
like to give rope to let people,
hey look,
I just asked you a lot of really broad
questions.
If you didn't know where you were
talking about,
you would have hung yourself.
I in this instance,
I don't think you did,
but I've had guests that I think do,
but those I,
those are criticisms I'm more than happy
to address and I,
I hope that five years from now I'm so
much of a better interviewer that I look
back on this and think this is shit.
I want to be better.
I want to be that.
But if you're,
if you're going a jumping off point is
this guy's a right wing extremist,
well then we're,
we're not going to really do this,
but I think what we've done here for the
hour is pretty good.
We're going to wrap this thing cause
we're,
we're going to dinner with some friends
cause we don't,
we didn't make up this friendship thing
were no,
it's a legitimate,
no,
it wasn't an artifact of a say.
Yeah.
You want to get drunk or what?
Probably yeah,
probably.
I'm only supposed cause my diamond a low
sugar diet is interesting.
So I'm only supposed to drink Pinot
grigio now.
So I've been drinking a ton of that.
So,
uh,
I think that's our,
I like the red,
but it was a pleasure as always.
And we have to do these more than once a
year because I think it's a good,
it's a good catch up and it's a good,
uh,
I have no problem.
You grading whether I've moved forward
or or,
or breast or whatever.
I think it would be a fun thing.
Yeah.
And,
and who knows where our ideas are going
to go.
Who knows how our beliefs will change
when we're confronted button new
evidence.
But here's what we do know.
If either one of us thinks that we've
gone off the rails or that we've made a
mistake,
we're going to call it out to the other
one and we're going to do so in the
context of a friendship.
Well said for more on Peter Boghossian
orb,
and he doesn't mind which way you say
it.
A follow him on the twitter,
although he may not check as mentioned
to that much at Peterborough.
Roseann.